Bruce I gotta ask you Knight has this
Halloween party every year called yeah
Xiao Bai yeah we okay this is a picture
Bruce of you with your good friend
attending the party I think you're
dressed as the twins and shine
here it is I just I don't look that you
like to take out every now and then you
like to go out like that every now and
again yeah the hair never had a chance
yeah I never had a chance is this a fun
you have you going to be you got to this
is what I was told if I didn't go to
Shama Wien I probably wouldn't have a
job on Monday oh yeah okay they really
nights very into Shamu II and what
happens it's check can you describe
Shamu we know it's virtue it's for
charity wonderful thing charity event
let's get that out of the way get that
out of we is just not really my jam yeah
you know so I got something doing it
means something to him which is why I
went so we showed up that's not
everybody showed up with everybody in
touch that yeah oh yeah Enya was some I
don't ever where she was it wasn't my
fault I was working I was working on
something different I really dedicated
much
I did not stop stirring about how much
I'd like gave up on Shamu wean for like
a solid two and a half months later it
was like you missed it you missed it you
missed it it was great it's party
everybody got drunk
you